the drums of war thunder once again hey
youtubers it's Charlie so big update on
the warcraft movie from duncan jones and
legendary it looks like Colin Farrell
and Paula Patton are going to be playing
lead roles in the film so let's talk
about who they're playing and what it
means for the movie if you haven't been
reading about the movie recently it
looks like the story that are going to
adapt for the script is going to be the
first war between the orcs and the
humans for anyone that's played the game
that's basically the first game before
Warcraft two types of darkness the movie
is supposed to shoot in January so I'm
totally not surprised they're making
casting announcements this early I
expect that we'll find out who's going
to be in the rest of the movie by the
end of the year because the film is
covering the medieval era and the first
war it looks like Colin Farrell is
probably going to be playing king of the
humans King adamant burned the third and
Paula Patton will be playing his wife
varia in case you're not sure who those
characters are let's do a quick crash
course in Warcraft lore it's really
really big it's a lot like Star Wars
Expanded Universe like there's a bunch
of books and comic books and tie ins and
stories so let's just cover the events
that are going to happen in this movie
the Ferrell's character king adamant was
actually king of Azeroth before the orcs
invaded that was basically before the
humans become fractured and before the
land masses separated like you see in
the game maps now the person that opened
the Dark Portal and allowed the orcs to
come through the burning legion that is
was medieval eli k human mage who is
supposed to fight the Burning Legion but
his soul was corrupted by the demon
sargeras who's basically the leader of
the Burning Legion during the midst of
this movie they'll actually live in
stormwind for people that have played
the game and it looks like Madiba
actually in the lore visited stormwind
so she might be in this movie too but
during the events of the movie as Roth
is basically destroyed and the humans
have to travel to Lord Iran a lot of
these places are going to be really
surreal in the movie because most of us
that have played the game have already
seen them all and because we're playing
them like much further in the future not
all of them look the same as they will
in this movie it's likely that they'll
use the second game the tides of
darkness those storylines in the second
war for the second movie but during the
events of the first movie Colin
Farrell's character at least in the
mythology and
dying and his son basically takes over
in the mage MIDI vol so dies too is
killed by a friend and ends up coming
back as a spirit in the next story as
well so all these characters actually as
much as they die end up coming back in
spirit form so even if Colin Farrell
does die in the first movie it's totally
possible that he will be in the second
movie as a spectral ghost though like i
said though if you want to find out
what's happening in the sequel just go
back and play warcraft to again is an
awesome game i mean it's just a lot of
fun anyway so let me know what you think
about them using the first war and colin
farrell and Paula Patton these actors
this should be pretty interesting Colin
Farrell has done a lot of different
movies but I'm mostly excited that
they're starting really early on on the
Lord just because it gives them a good
place to go I don't know how close
they're going to stick to the text
though but let me know what you think it
is reassuring to know that they're going
to rely on a lot of the back stories
that people have already created for
these characters I don't think they're
going to be changing a lot from these
movies but if you want to know what the
movie might look like then watch some of
Duncan Jones as other films he did
source code with jake gyllenhaal aided
moon with Sam Rockwell so he's mostly
known for doing small films but you can
kind of expect this to be a semi CG semi
real life obviously I don't think
they're going to be spending more than
maybe like 150 million dollars so a lot
of it won't be full-blown sets it'll be
a lot of CG stuff the movie will be a
comic con next year but i would expect
they're going to save all the good stuff
for blizzcon so if you really want to be
one of the first people to see this
movie make sure you buy a ticket to
blizzcon in an interesting twist of fate
legendary is making this films as
partners with Nerdist who I am a partner
with now so i'll definitely try and do
some cool behind-the-scenes videos for
this movie is it moves along obviously
they're not shooting till January so
most of the news that we're going to get
in the next couple of months is mostly
going to be about the story and the cast
you should have subscribe to get those
videos in the meantime you can learn it
all about James Spader becoming Ultron
in the Avengers sequel right here and
you can click here to get my latest
attack on tight review that's ending
next week so be sure to check it out
it's really awesome anime series thanks
for watching for Azeroth
you